[Musique]
bonjour marcellin nadeau
bonjour maurice wolton bonjour aux
auditrices et auditeurs de martinez
premières radios et des salutations
sympathique à l'équipe de la matinale
très sympathique et qui peut dire merci
pour cette équipe co présidents de pays
à un mouvement politique présenté
dimanche dernier robert co président
avec jean philippe miller qui a quitté
le mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais marcellin nadeau à peine
créé et qu'il vous ait suggéré de
changer de communiquera à cause du nom
que vous avez choisi paya qui est vu par
il ya de montplaisir comme trop proche
de son bas pays en chance alors déjà
nous n'avons pas de communiquer aussi à
certains qui peuvent sans ce pays des
communicants je suis très heureux pour
eux mais nous n'avons pas des moyennes
mais je dois dire qu'ils ont sur les
communicants de bap et en chansons
beaucoup puisé dans la créativité
populaire à travers pays ac thann où il
ya dix en espèces et puis aussi bâtir le
pays martinique avec et nous aussi a
fait nous sommes en résonance avec la
créativité populaire c'est le à partir
de longs débats de dialogue de
discussions que nous avons trouvé ce nom
qui concourent bien avec noens nos
aspirations et celles du peuple
martiniquais la classe politique
martiniquaise s'approprient l'espace
géographique veut faire savoir qu'elle
entend faire peuple qu'elle entend
s'enraciner satorp ansa mais je crois
que c'est très important parce que
finalement nous sommes dans un pays où
c'est le le le san suu kyi le sport
national comme dirait est revenu ici
n'est ce pas ce psychologue guadeloupéen
d'origine christine d'ailleurs et je
crois qu'il faut absolument sortir parce
qu'on voit tout le mal que ça fait au
pays créé un espace un de nos objectifs
d'ailleurs riz un espace politique
apaisée nous voyons notre mouvement
comme pacificateur de l'espace politique
martic
non pas que nous sommes pour une
sauteuse d'angélisme unanimiste mais
c'est parce que justement nous croyons
aussi dans l'affirmation des convictions
mais nous croyons que à travers des
démarches démocratique eh bien nous
pouvons à la fois nous exprimer éclairer
l'opinion publique pour des choix
démocratiques en même temps le faire en
toute sérénité et dans le plus grand
respect des uns et des autres notre
signal fort ce sont les couleurs de
votre logo le rouge le vert le noir là
encore c'est une affirmation
une différenciation par rapport à
d'autres non moi je dire une infirmière
une affirmation parce que nous voyons
les choses en positiver et je crois que
je tiens à dire d'ailleurs que nous ne
sommes pas nés pour che qui que ce soit
nous croyons à la diversité et à la
richesse mans possible de tous et de
chacun à travers la diversité y compris
des partis politiques mais en tout cas
nous avons tenu effectivement à faux
affirmé cet ancrage dans cette nation
qui la nation martiniquaise et
reconnaître ses couleurs qui ont été
portées par des gens qui ont lutté pour
sa reconnaissance et notre
reconnaissance
or au niveau du monde entier alors quels
sont les retours depuis dimanche dernier
marcellin nadeau a très positif on a
beaucoup d'enseignements c'est le
déficit avait été fier de l'être il est
beau il est souriant mais mais faut bien
justement qu' il soit un moment donné
porté par cette association en tout cas
nous donner tous les moyens de mettre en
place le cadet qui nous permettra de
durer dans le temps parce que notre
objectif c'est de durer pourquoi pas
durer pour nous faire plaisir mais durer
parce que le peuple martiniquais a
besoin d'une force politique qui pense
la politique autrement et qui prône une
autre manière de faire de la politique
un seul être n'était pas là et cela
suffit pour alimenter toutes les
conversations bruno nestor azérot le
maire de sète marie l'ami le frère de
jean philippe hiller l'incontournable du
nord dont le poids électoral de sa
commune peut être déterminant il y avait
des explications cela en tout cas bruno
nice 3 0 est invité comme tous les
maires de martinique et tous les
parlementaires bon pensait qu'il serait
venu bon il n'est pas venu je ne sais
pour quelle raison ce que je voudrais
dire quand même c'est qu'il n'ya aucune
sorte d'animosité entre vounetz 3 0 et
avec jean philippe noiret avec moi même
sur les étangs jean philippe miller a
dit lors d'une émission télé une chose
qui est très juste pipo et l'église ses
clochers on se connaît la proximité
idéologique qui est qui entre nous
imaginez qu'on dise tout de suite année
ce tournoi 02 venez avec nous on aurait
dit à eux ils se sont d électoraliste
leur seul objectif c'est les élections
ils veulent conquérir les places et les
postes mais c'est pas notre objectif
notre objectif justement c'est de créer
une force politique qui porte un projet
alternatif et pour ce faire qui peut
s'appuyer sur les mobilisations
populaires et des pratiques d'acteurs
martiniquais mais nous nous optons pleut
plus larges comme j'aurais aimé césaire
contre le plus étroit et nous pensons
que new moves notre mouvement d'une part
va s'élargir et eu un moyen de passer
des alliances électorales y compris avec
le mythe de
winona demeure un ami il ya une
passerelle à construire avec lui oui
absolument
comme avec d'autres d'ailleurs autre
question tellement focus sur ni lors
qu'ils divorcent de marie-jeanne qu'on a
oublié de voir avec qui il travaillera
et puis vous êtes apparu comme ça
brusquement vous avez manifestement le
sens du secret qu'il faut garder
jusqu'au dernier moment ce sont des deux
premiers pions marcellin nadeau jubilant
denax qui se veut fort sans faire injure
aux autres de pays à vous focaliserait
des regards mais quels seraient les
raisons pour que les 385 milles
martiniquais s'arrête sur ce duo il orne
nadeau c'est à dire que loin de bouder
la symbolique et qui est forte je lave
ou ce que nous voulons surtout c'est
amener un peu de rationalité dans
l'espace politique le des passionnés
pour amener le martiniquais à la
réflexion sur la situation du des
passionnés oui c'est possible situation
inique
nous essaierons autant que possible pour
amener les gens à raisonner par rapport
à lass est un pays qui souffre
énormément ce pays qui perd 2,2 de sa
jeunesse c'est un pays qui a un nombre
important de difficultés de
contradictions qui dure depuis longtemps
et qu'il faut absolument résoudre ce qui
est important pour nous c'est que nous
croyons aussi dans les valeurs dont nous
sommes les héritiers
jean philippe et moi même de tout ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le mouvement qui
colle aux martiniquais depuis saisir
jusqu'à l' frais de marie-jeanne en
passant par le loup pulvar et garcin
malsa mais nous disons effectivement qui
avait fait une réflexion à mener c'est
la manière de porter les valeurs de ce
mouvement là et pour la manière de
concrétiser montrer au peuple
martiniquais qu'il s'agit pas de
discourir pour discourir mais qu'il
s'agit bien de régler les contradictions
qui font que nous sommes dans cette
situation aujourd'hui mais vous pensez
bien que c'est normal qu'on se pose la
question compte tenu des sommes de leur
personnalité de leur parcours de leurs
idéologies des histoires de vos
mouvements politiques respectives c'est
normal qu'on se pose la question mais
justement nous pensons que pendant très
longtemps
notre mouvance global a souffert des
divisions entre hommes des divisions qui
était aussi la base de divergences nous
disons que est ce que nous ne pouvons
pas à chaque fois essayé de rechercher
le plus petit dénominateur commun pour
trouver les synergies
parce qu'on a besoin de se rassembler je
le dis bien avoir se rassemblent et ça
ne veut pas dire effacer les
contradictions des différences ça veut
dire reconnaître les différences est
dans une forme d'intercompréhension et
porter ensemble justement le projet
alternatif que le peuple martiniquais
attend
et puis le principe même de celle celui
de la présidence bicéphale on a vu
tellement de la lyre certainement promet
triste tellement tout ça ollier prendre
un vol non je crois que c'est important
nous sommes dans une démarche il faisait
nous disons qu'on a besoin de démocratie
nous disons qu'on a besoin de
collégialité
nous disons qu'il faut sortir de ces
logiques de chefs de guerre de chefs et
bien ce serait totalement contradictoire
que devenir un vent disant peu pratique
et voilà nous avons un chèque unique par
un chèque un chef lionel saisissez le
nom nous disons contraire nous
démontrons notre capacité à être dans
une démarche collégiale et au delà de
nos deux personnages a fait les leurs et
moi même à travers cette coprésidence il
y a tout un bureau pluriel composée de
jeunes de moins jeunes et nous comptons
vraiment être dans une démarche de
collégialité quant à la direction de ce
mouvement
oui j'ai pu lire dans le france antilles
des témoignages on a pu entendre sur les
antennes de la première également
certaines personnes qui aux abords de
mansart de robert à dimanche dernier on
évoqué des pressions sur elle pour le
passeur rendent robert ne pas s'afficher
aux côtés de jean philippe miller est de
vous qui fait pression est ce qu'on est
déjà dans l'eure à l'heure du serrage
grimm
moi je ne sais pas parce
qu'effectivement j'ai entendu ça mais
les personnes qui l'ont qu'ils ont dit
non pas indiqué elle est ce qui pourrait
faire pression sur sur hem s'agissant
des personnes dont je suis pas en mesure
de dire ce que je veux dire c'est que
justement il faut absolument c'est notre
volonté mais très forte sortir de ces
logiques du cancan des pressions des
règlements de compte tout ça et stériles
inutiles
il ne nous fait pas avancer je le dis je
le répète ce que nous voulons c'est un
espace politique pacifiées mais avec des
convictions de réel débat démocratique
sur des orientations à prendre
quant à l'avenir de ce peuple de ce pays
et sur le fond bleu des thèmes qui vous
rapproche et se battre contre les
dépendances j'en fait il en a souvent
évoqué c'est un des thèmes majeurs de ce
rapprochement ni leur nadeau absolument
je crois que à travers ce ce que
développe jean-philippe nylon sur la
la diminution fait des dépôts des
dépendances on peut retrouver aussi la
question de la conquête des espaces de
souveraineté il s'agit effectivement de
d'occuper des espaces dans nos
associations dans les syndicats dans nos
coopératives où on mis en avant le
principe de responsabilité martiniquaise
et bien avant
on peut commencer c'est pas la peine
d'attendre d'être mère au conseil
municipal ou conseiller territorial on
peut commencer déjà dans nos structures
de bases organisationnelles auxois
syndicales ou associatives
mais après effectivement je crois qu'il
est important à travers bon tout ce que
nous pourrons créer comme dynamique
majoritaire est bien de porter
effectivement ce principe de
responsabilité martiniquaise de façon
concrète et dit aussi que effectivement
il faudrait peut-être élargir le champ
de nos responsabilités c'est une
question qu'il faudra se poser mais nous
croyons également qu'il faudra savoir se
saisir des leviers existants aujourd'hui
pour mettre en oeuvre les politiques
publiques nécessaires justement à abane
évolution positive de ce peuple à vous
est déjà prêt pour 2021 vous êtes en
campagne mais justement notre objectif
exclusif n'est pas les élections je
disais s'écrie une force politique
nous avons fait beaucoup de
préoccupation aujourd'hui on sait que
l'expansion series agacé que vous serez
au sérieux nous a dit qu'on dit pas on
ira aux élections et d'évident n'est pas
de ceux qui disent que les élections ne
sera rien nous irons aux élections
mais avant les élections nous devons
construire cette force pour porter les
revendications du peuple martiniquais à
travers un certain nombre de
problématiques notamment sanitaires
écologiques je vais parler des sargasses
j'ai parlé du chlordécone j'ai parlé de
problèmes de la qualité de l'air
bref et tous les problèmes économiques
sociaux de de cherté exister exister en
s'emparant de ses thèmes qui sont
essentiels pour le pays mais absolument
c'est ça être ça dit être au coeur du
peuple pour porter ces revendications
c'est de ne pas transformer la politique
en simple jeu électoral il faut sortir
de cette logique où on est exclusivement
politique dans un but électoral la
politique n'est pas un jeu
c'était quelque chose de sérieux des
journaux nationaux et ceux qui
expliquent le discrédit en fait de la
classe politique
si je peux parler de classe politique
c'est parce que les gens sont souvent
déçus ces gens sont déçus parce que
justement et les politiques n'arrivent
pas à répondre à leurs aspirations
pourquoi parce qu'on est toujours dans
ce jeu électoraliste de
conquérir et de se maintenir coûte que
coûte au pri au pouvoir nous croyons
effectivement que la politique peut être
moyen pour les populations et bien de
trouver à s'exprimer de manière à
trouver des solutions à leurs
problématiques et à leurs problèmes en
quelques secondes comment comment
rallumer la flamme pour cette population
désabusée
parce qu'elle parle d'une classe
politique désabusé discrédit discréditer
plus tôt mais je dois vous dire que j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir que cette flamme sera
rallumée que l'espoir soit retrouvé la
confiance également lorsque j'ai vu le
nombre de personnes qui étaient présents
justement soeur de robert dimanche
dernier merci marcellin nadeau d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin dans son caddie
on rappelle que vous êtes co présidents
de pays à aux côtés de jean philippe
miller bureau politique qui a fait son
apparition sur la scène politique locale
dimanche dernier robert merci bonne
journée
merci
[Musique]